це відео
потенційних учасників аукціону
то це є надзвичайно крута подія яка
організована молодіжкою яка
експонати в лоте аукціону вкладені
найдорожче найважливіше і
вкладна душа і я дуже розраховую на вашу
підтримку шановні учасники
аукціону дінари і Марина розкажуть як це
буде буде виданий певний час тиждень або
більше коли ви зможете давати своє
замовлення і я хочу сказати що ця карта
Це є дуже проста вашої родини Це дійсно
Марина сказала я твердо переконую
Рубіжне Це є символ українського опору
на сході Луганської області і те що це
зроблено в саме в таких умовах дуже
важливо це символ Сходу України Мені не
вистачало якого знаєте символу півдня
я його знайшов
це дуже крута штука називається аналоги
в нет
це ак-12 вони Коли прийшли до нас
сказали що це найкраща стрілецька зброя
якою озброєні
скловській і десантники
які прийшли в Херсонську область
саме з цим автоматам називається війна
каждый нас
вбивати українців
зіткнулися вони
ну для правоохоронних органів сказали що
я йшов по Києву і от тут знайшов
біля входу галакс но подарували його
мені наша
шоста рота нашого 206 батальйону
з наших позицій в Херсонській області
покупцю я скажу місце
і підрозділ слова які ми вилучили для
участі в аукціоні подарую фото бмд
бойової машини десанту яка була Як то
кажуть що зупинена
нашою шостою ротою і за цей тиждень ми
ще попросимо діначки розмалювати
патріотичні кольори цей автомат так от
пропонується А как 12
аналогів єдине що хочу одразу попередити
він буде розсверлений і
неможливо і для бойового застосування і
буде
гарною колекційною зброєю подарунків
скорських десантників які були розбиті і
знищені Херсонській області України це
буде символ нашої Перемоги отже
робить ваші пропозиції по аукціону ак-12
від московських десантників
виставляється лот 6 ротою 206 батальйону
і я наполегливо раджу
купить ак-12
років
Залишаємо я хотів його віднести
і я думаю що тут він надійних руках
друзі дуже круто беруть участь аукціоні
бо кожна копійка з тих грошей щоб ви
заплатите в аукціон нашої молодіжкою
буде використано найефективнішим чином і
ви пам'ятаєте одна гривня на аукціон від
вас
одна гривня від благодійного фонду
Порошенка від нас і це вдвічі здвічі
ефективність для збройних сил кожної
вашої це вже непожертв це вже повільно
Дякую Слава збройним силам України і
слава Україні
друзі усім Отже підтримуємо разом наших
збройних сил України і Ми дякуємо
Брати по зброї Ми дякуємо справу громад
в першу чергу Ми дякуємо нашу Молодіжку
і Ми дякуємо твою браму ви великим
молодці і Дякую що ви рано
[оплески]
організація яка
забезпечує рішення
кидати в різні двері
навіть декілька тисяч
проект
Визначте які нам допомогли
сьогодні присутні
або родину про нас створювали і відео
Чоловік записував як її правильно
Так звичайно
привітаємо останній день
[оплески]
настільки об'єдналися за цей період і
дуже круто
я вірю нашу перемогу ми всі ці
віримо і я просто дуже хвилююся
я б цього аукціону дійсно не було би без
кооперації без любові до України і без
підтримки я неймовірно вдячна твоїй
брамі громадську організації яка
звернулась до всіх нас і ми всі разом
тут день і ніч
створювали
найкращій простір для того аби показати
наскільки наші українські митці митці
готові навіть
на шоломах російських малювати квітучу і
розвинуту Україну тому ми просимо
долучатися до цього онлайн аукціону і
всі ми разом можемо вважати що аукціон
Незламні відкрити
залишайтеся підтримайте свої правила
Кримська я попрошу тебе От подивись на
цей якби це надихнуло тебе на якісь
такі стався тим хто переможе цей аукці
он я допоможу можна побажання георгії
пані обра
ти безкоштовно
[музика]
будь ласка спасибі велике ми залишаємо
Марина
і долучаємо
сь в соціальних мережах
долучатись до сторінки в
Фейсбуці
і село ти і обирати найкраще і
будете так само буде долучатися і
боротися за деяких експонати і залишимо
це на пам'ять за
щоб відчувати силу в боротьбі Я ще раз
дякую солідарні молоді я дякую
художникам Діана дрині якщо ти тут де ти
я
Діана
подивіться на цю на цю тему їжі
яка нині ніч малювала Дякую вам дякую що
тут є ще художники молоді які долуча
лися до цього процесу варили з уламків
російських уламків творили те що може
показати що наша країна вистачить І от
один год перед вашими очима тому шановні
друзі глядачі просимо всіх долучатися до
онлайну Незламні фон Порошенка твоя
брама солідарна молодь зробить усе
можливе аби забезпечити наших хлопців
ЗСУ мені необхідним І дай боже ми
поїдемо разом з вами своїм брамою на
донеччину з автомобілем який
їм потрібен і
був Тому Слава Україні і ми точно
переможемо правильно
що ж друзі Всім привіт Сьогодні з вами
європейська Солідарність
солідарна молодь
та фонд Порошенка
зараз у нас організований аукціон
Не забувайте по-перше ставити лайки та
підтримувати а по-друге
переходити за посиланням яке ми зараз
покажемо
вам
яке ви зараз почитаєте в коментарях і ви
Звісно ж перейдете і Можливо ви оберете
собі щось з цього
питання
тут Тут є і шоломи росіян і зроблені з
боєприпасів
експонат і діда мой можете побачити
і навіть шоломи смерть росіян
дуже-дуже красиві картини
боєприпаси шоломи
і
найголовніше що тут є це
можна сказати подарунок для цього
аукціону Петро Олексійович приніс
автомат ак-12 це подарунок скоріше
відсковських десантників
які
залишили його після
дуже-дуже вдалого рукавичках звичайно
штурму
і ви прямо зараз приходячи за посиланням
в коментарях
можете його купити
організатори цього заходу це ви можете
побачити фон Порошенка
солідарна молодь та твоя брама
зараз фотографуємось
і це у нас розмальована
гусениці від танку
її декілька ночей наскільки мені відомо
малювали і робили
всі хто хоче сфотографуватися підходьте
ми тут вишукуємося
дивіться сюди Оце я тут
так швидко сфотографуватися
[музика]
давайте поки подивимось
чином експонати
Нагадую що купити придбати
точніше взяти участь у їх придбанні ви
можете за посиланням
яке ви бачите в коментарях і
гроші які будуть виручені за рахунок
цього аукціону підуть на збройні сили
України
[музика]
і ця сторона друзі теж далі
»
[музика]
.»
ну і звісно присутні Петро Олексійович
Марина Анатоліївна Порошенка
[музика]
така ж приїхали журналісти
на мене будь ласка
добре
сині вас за вітання
Дякую друзі
[музика]
ви великі молодці
зараз я пропоную квартиру знайти
знайти та запитати художників які робили
ці всі експонати
подивитися
[музика]
під цим стрімом також переходити в
коментарі
74 показували тому Ну цікаво було просто
порівняти
Єгор
і не забувайте що цей автомат ви можете
спробувати придбати за посиланням яке
буде в
[музика]
описів в коментарях
і також Дивіться яка у нас є тут мапа
мапа з кордонами України Ну як сказав з
правильними карданами України від ціну
додому але
це карта
держави Скоропадського
і сам і Дон
А це дивіться
наші воїни взяли
шматок цього тану
передали його нам і вже
художники які знаходяться по різних
куточках країни
переробили його і зробили з нього ось
такий Марк
л
Україна
Як у вас справи
Дуже дякую Привіт
можеш розповісти нам про картини які то
намалювали
пішли пішли до них
[музика]
картину
скажи про неї
ну власне я отримала запит від
волонтерської організації Твоя правда у
них була ідея як потрібно було цю
картину зобразити і вони звернулися з
тим щоб її якби втілити в життя
ідея була в тому що це був настільки
непередбачуваний для нас напад що навіть
якщо хтось подумав але все одно До кінця
не вірили і тут видно всю темря готує цю
е-е весь час живим і
ну їх може працювати органами можуть
хочеться Це просто армію темряви і наше
блакитне небо
поле яке все одно буде жити навіть після
того як його знищили клас Дуже гарно
Дуже гарно А я так розумію Путін тут
зображений у ролі хіппера правильно і
кольори вибрані теж
сировини власне Він у мене вийшов
не знаю на
мабуть навіть на Лукашенка а потім вже
він перерізав Путіна не знаю якось так
мабуть диктатори всі з'являються самі
собою на картинах Клас Клас
друзі Нагадую що цю картину ви можете
придбати як лот на сторінках які
посилання на яке ми залишимо в
коментарях
і давайте подивимось чи другу картину
розкажи як вона називається
людей власне це про тих людей які так
довго боронили місто Маріуполь і про тих
людей які досі залишаються там при тому
вони є справжніми українцями і тими хто
чекають просто коли нарешті
люди які залишилися будинках люди які
живуть в будівлі яких власне вже немає
маленький символ того що все одно
залишається Україною
Це моя так
так А скажи як довго от саме цю картину
Ти намалювала у мене насправді Коли я
дивлюсь на неї в мене коли я вперше її
побачив вона тут ще
була день тому і у мене були мурахи по
шкірі Розкажи будь ласка як
ну ідея я розумію наскільки довго ти її
малювала і скільки сил ти вклала у цю
картину
а власне вона в мене більше
продуктивніше виходила вночі Бо якось
Воно мабуть під настрій мінус так більше
Вночі вона створювалась краще а-а
настрій для цього повинен бути був Ну
мабуть не веселим бо важко було
сконцентруватися на тому що ти малюєш
руїни фактично
зайнялася картина по виготовленню десь
декілька днів створювала її декілька
днів і декілька ночей
власне інші замовлення трішки почекали
поки вона створювалась
Тобто ти є малювала саме З натхненням Ну
коли
в тебе в один момент воно прийшло і ти
поки не закінчила ти її малювала чи чи
якось не так Саме так і до речі
закінчувала її в ніч приблизно о пів на
7 ранку Коли Київ пролетіли трони і якщо
тому мабуть останніми мазками були ці
більш чорні плями тому що настрій
Які ж саме саме чорні плями
адже його також
знайти тебе я б псевдонім чи ти малюєш
від свого імені Я малюю в Інстаграмі В
мене просто свій власний нікнейм А так
як скажи його
аліарт Ага дякую не забувайте
підписуватись дуже красиві картини і між
іншим цю картину ви теж можете придбати
діалог і ви можете підтримувати ЗСУ
спробувати поборотися за неї та отримати
Я не знаю це напевно Символ це певна
пам'ять в
у своїй квартирі про ті страшні речі які
російська армія робить з українськими
містами
але тут дуже багато моментів які
показують нашу незалежність
кожна людина яка знаходиться там тримає
свічку в руках тягнеться один до одного
підтримує один одного тому це не лише
показати але ще про позитив дякую вам
дуже
друзья давайте також запитаємо у
творців твоя брама про цей аукціон як в
них виникли йде і
як саме
взагалі відбувалося зародження
так Вітаю це один можемо пройти трошки
от сюди щоб не заважати
друзі Вітаю це один з засновників Я так
розумію
[музика]
заступник голови власне організації
громадської твоя брама це власне
ініціатори цього
аукціону цього проекту Розкажіть як
виникла взагалі де
спілкуватися
тільки не починаю переходити на
українську мову
ти виникла з місця три назад
для того чтобы можно было
більше зібрати коштів для помощи нашим
військом
деякі люди на жаль таких багато читає
що в Києві все завершилось
от і
стала тяжко збирати гроші бо от про це
прийшла ідея
цю війну цю біль українського народу
виразити от в мистецтві
який нам передали розмальовано
він розмальований з історії
дуже цікаво
це війна початок війни
от
російська Лапа да наша дівчина
[музика]
шолом присвячений Азову це бієць боєць
який унічтожает
це
шолом який був знятий з горка
з Мертвого
це місце
влучання осколка того пробіла всьо і
слава богу да ніколи не пробачтесь от це
єсть
очень символічна
можна було взяти ціле шолом але это
історія
буржуйка яку розмальовувала тоже наша
художниця
от початок
І так от по кругу вся історія читається
оськи
10 крадуть стиральную машинники
дуже круто дуже круто приходять Та ні на
концерт Кобзон
це наша Ідея цього малюнку просто
художниця виплатила його життя
[музика]
по картину художниця присутня зараз тут
На жаль ми вже знаємо
одна із картин зроблена
де яка
картинка должна бути Після чотирьох
часів і она по телефону
А це гусениці
це
солідарна мова
дуже дуже
інтересно тоже воно все виглядає от
це Юг України
арбузи Орки херсонцев
[музика]
в такому
77-го року
1977 рік
А це я так розумію шолом теж вбитого
горка
з проломана
щоб було видно
друзі не забувайте ставити лайки Та не
забувайте що в коментарях ви можете
знайти посилання на цей аукціон і купити
ну спробувати Скажімо так купити
будь-яку з цих речей які ви зараз тут
бачите і
всі виручені Кошти які ми зберемо за
цей тиждень за найближчий тиждень вони
підуть на збройні сили України
это
скульптура
нашого бійця
зробив
[музика]
це боєць робив його
залізний майстер от його
ми йому дали все це просто було купа
[музика]
Іди домой
круто круто Дякую вам за таку ідею за
такі класні це такий класний проект як
мінімум і коротше Що ми робимо цю
спільну справу разом і разом точно
переможемо
Слава Україні Героям слава
[музика]
друзі не забувайте ставити лайки
ділитися цим стрімом
бо Чим більше людей дізнається про це
аукціон тим більше грошей нам вдасться
зібрати і відправити їх на збройні сили
України
[музика]
вітаю
у нас Молодіжка друзі і зараз ми ще
хочемо взяти коментар у людини яка
розмальовувала
одні з експонатів
Не забувайте Не забувайте ставити лайки
це реально зараз дуже важливо Не
забувайте ділитися в соцмережах Не
забувайте
поширювати відео у тому числі на своїй
сторінці лайкати
документувати
тому що усе це просуває
нашу сторінку і усе це просуває просуває
[музика]
цей аукціон і чим більше лайків ми
збираємо тим більше буде охоплення і тим
більше ми зможемо зібрати коштів на
збройні сили України Привіт Привіт
Розкажи хто ти
розкажи Я так розумію щось з цих
експонатів робилося мети
це інсталяція подій яка які були вночі
коли звідти вибила наша українська армія
Русь вона символізує типу танки зверху а
макове поле це як кров наших воїнів які
там полеглими і не тільки воїнів а також
Мирний
лялька-мо
танка А яка символізує незламність
України українського народу і також
лялька-мотанка це як символ оберегу в
Україні
Ось і ось ця інсталяція з маком
мак який розквів на полі
яке
вібрало кров українських воїнів які
захищали нашу землю
друзі не забувайте що усі ці експонати
про які ми зараз розповіли і про які ми
розповіли трошки раніше ви можете
придбати на сторінках спеціальних які
були створені під цей аукціон і кожна
витрачена гривня цього аукціону піде на
збройні сили України ба більше фонд
Порошенка який є теж співрорганізатором
цього заходу цього аукціону
подвоїть усі кошти зароблені
на продажу цих всіх фігурок Дякую тобі
дуже
дякую
кожного
хто буде
[музика]
поширювати наші роботи але зараз ми
хотіли би завершити з'їзд дуже приємною
річчю ми не раз сказали про те що дуже
був складний рік і ми нашою командою
тож друзі ще раз посилання ви знайдете в
коментарях або посилання буде в самому В
самій підводці під Стрім
Ставте лайки
підписуйтесь
і
чим більше зберемо тим більше допоможемо
Дякуємо вам і Вірте в перемогу вірте
збройні сили і Тоді обов'язково перемог
Буде за нами